hi my name is Edwin Nichols I'm farallon
Ohio right outside of the actor there
are a lot of things to do in Akron one
of them is visiting the 17 metroparks I
am standing in the sand run metro park
right now in the metro parks you can ski
swim sled camp kayak and hike
I don't think to do in Akron visitors at
the cuyahoga valley national park the
National Park is the only national park
in Ohio and covers 125 miles as a
national park you can walk leave Ohio
and Erie Canal towpath trail it runs
from Cleveland to the Ohio River and
covers 308 marks
also you can visit a new at all Stan who
it also Tudor style style mansion
previously owned by the sideways fa
seiberling founded the Goodyear Tire
standard hall has three thousand livres
is complete with their copay course two
tennis courts and coal four hole golf
course familiar de music room a
gymnasium finna bullying it notable
people who sleep at see you at our home
color Thomas Edison prisons Taft
religion party and the Von Trapp family
one of the ways I study is to keep the
binder full of notes on different
countries and areas I get the
information on the countries from
different atlases the CIA world factbook
and National Geographic com
we're placing the world I would like to
visit the Galapagos Islands the
galapagos islands are home to many
different planes and angels some of
these species are found nowhere else on
the globe the Galapagos Islands made
famous by Charles Darwin Charles Darwin
created his theories of evolution and
natural selection on these islands off
the coast event
I hope you enjoy learning about me and
my community
you